and before you were a fighter you were a
bouncer
yeah i balanced out that bartender most
of the time but i was uh i broke up most
of the fights too in the bar but
i was a little it was a little easier
from behind the bar actually because you
could see people you could see it
happening bill you're hitting it before
it starts seeing you get in the fire
or i throw ice at him you know i just
throw ice at him hey is that how you get
the name dice man
no i wouldn't be funny
leave each other alone that's funny
though i picture you bartending
security's like uh chuck can you help us
please
my buddy chris pontius told me to ask
you about uh like
fighting with like a bunch of navy seals
yeah that that happened a long time but
people ask that all the time um
i mean it was for me i wasn't involved
in most of it uh the first time they
came in
most of all of us were all the guys like
that that train with me that that
normally working at that bar were in
hawaii with us like because we all went
to hawaii for our
our whole fight team went
and gan mcgee was still there
who's 6 10 uh
almost 300 pounds and he fought for ufc
world title at one point but he he was
involved in it he got he got caught i
got cut over his eye i got to cut
somewhere on his face i think and then
go with buddies really pissed off and
everyone's mad about it and then
they showed up again two weeks later and
and so the guys kind of
got got got back at him um i when i
showed up they had one of my buddies had
a guy panda the only thing i did was
i ran over hey and this guy's was
hitting my buddy when he had the guy the
guy started hitting everybody he had him
pin i ran over the snap head snapped the
guy bounced his face off the ground
uh so he lost his head
what did he just grab his head grabbed
his head and just just
moved back and pulled his head down and
slapped his head off he just hit his
head off the ground he went out he went
out and cut open his head i think that
seems a little bit out of character for
you i think that you strike me as more
of a
uh put them in a like like choke them
out and then lay them down nice and soft
typically that that would i don't but i
don't once once it goes to throwing
punches i i don't do that i one had to
do that one time in college and got
kicked in the face while i was doing it
like never again so i once once a bunch
of people are throwing punches i i i try
to keep my hands free so it's like a
snap and that's quick okay
i'm gonna get them off it keeps them
quick it gets it over and it's it's
quick
um yeah i don't know
hawaii or san francisco san luis obispo
you went to slo okay
i say i lived there for 20 years that
was my most my whole fight career yeah
so but yeah but
people ask about that i had a guy i got
an extra cr maybe maybe he's still
assuming asked me if i was mad at him
and i'm like
no like
it was a bar fight it happened it
happens [ __ ] happens i mean it's or
whatever like
for what like
it was just you know i think pawnee's
asked about that or told me to ask about
that because pontius is from san luis
obispo oh wow so i think uh
it's like a local legend yeah i imagine
so yeah
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you